hey Conan O'Brien here I hope like me
you're staying calm
you're staying safe and you're staying
at home avoiding crowds one thing people
are worried about is where can they get
hand sanitizer that's right some guy
came along went to the store and he
bought up all the hand sanitizer and he
has much more than he needs and he's
just sitting on it he wants like ten
thousand dollars a squirt the guy who do
you go to boo by boom body that's just a
character I came up with but I bet
that's exactly what the guy sounds like
we're gonna do body you could buy my
sanitizer it's just a guy I came up with
yeah I don't have a name for him yet but
I'm working on it
the point is this don't worry about
buying hand sanitizer you can make it at
home and I'll show you how right now
start off with a bottle of Tito's vodka
so you take your Tito's okay pour out a
little bit to make room next ingredient
Listerine just about that much should do
you want this stuff to spread on real
nice and smooth that's where Kiehl's
hand lotion comes in and just make sure
you get a lot of kills in there next
garlic garlic kills everything just to
ask a vampire that jokes free get a
Windex bottle that you've got around the
house take the squatcher which is what I
call it screw that on and bingo bango
bongo you are ready to go
look at that look look at that look at
it look at that hold on a second here we
go what the keels broken
don't put as much keels in as I did
still this will work just fine
hands are drunk hope that helped
be well